COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
RESPONSE THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND BASE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ADMIN MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISSING PARLIAMENT'S. ALLOW
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL REE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POST IN OUR
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT. NOW TO
PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
ONE DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WHEN MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THERE MAY BE A SHORT
WAITING PERIOD ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT.
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE GLAD YOU DID
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE IMMEDIATELY PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOIS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS TO
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND CLOSE
THE SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
TO MAYBE SOMETIME LAGS. FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF THE ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
DO THE CONSTRAINTS. OF
REGARDING LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS I'M IS
SITTING TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY WHICH WILL BE FURTHER
ANNOUNCED AS WE- PROCEED-
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONAL
DAYS BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM AMBERG.
AMBERG HERE BURGESS MORE JUST
FRIENDS AND CARRY IT OUT. RIGHT
AT THE DEATH SO. GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG JONES JONES HERE
LAYERED HERE LAYERED HERE STERN.
WHITE HOUSE SKI WHY CASKEY HERE
WINNER. WELL WE SEEM TO BE
MISSING ONE US SENATOR- GOOD
SOULS IS HERE. OKAY FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM CAPITAL. DID I SO ONCE I
LIVE. GONZALEZ HERE HERTZBERG
STERN WINNER YOU HAVE A QUORUM
PRESENT. THANK YOU MAN TO KILL
SO WE HAVE A POOR WE HAVE
FOURTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S CHAT
AGENDA TANNER ON CONSENT THE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ARE AS FOLLOWS FILE NUMBER ONE
A. B. THREE SEVEN EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARCA CAN UP A
NUMBER FOR AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FILE NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FIFTEEN EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FILE I'M NUMBER SIXTEEN. EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUR ONE BY SOME OF THE
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE A NUMBER SEVEN
AB EIGHT NINE ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUTTING HIM FILE
I'M NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR TO
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEGAN
DOLLY FROM NUMBER NINE A. B.
FOUR FIVE THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER
CHRISTINA GARCIA FILE NUMBER
TEN A. B. FOUR ONE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MANTIA AND FILE
AND I'M NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN BY SEVEN
MEMBER- THE ARTIST. AND FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
TO SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WALDRON THE MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CENTER LAYERS
MOVE MOVES THE CONSENT KELLER-MAN CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AMBERG HI AMBER I
PORGES. GORGEOUS.. THERE ONE SIDE. GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG. JOAN JOHN HI LEHRER.
LATER I STERN WHITE HOUSE. WHY
CASKEY I WINNER. YOU HAVE SIX
SO FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL I SEE IS THE ONLY
MEMBER BANNER HORROR IS HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME TO THE
SENATE ARE YOU PREPARED I AM
PREPARED ALL RIGHT. OF GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB THREE THREE FIVE ALLOWS
MANUFACTURERS OF RECREATIONAL
BOATS THE MARINE ENGINES TO
RECEIVE AND RETAIN SPECIFIC
CONTACT INFORMATION. FOR BUYERS
OF ITS PRODUCTS FOR THE LIMITED
AND EXCLUSIVE USE OF CONDUCTING
PRODUCT SAFETY RECALLS AND
WARRANTY VERIFICATION. UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND PROPOSITION TWENTY
FOUR. APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ESTABLISHED
CONSUMER PRIVACY AND PERSONAL
DATA PROTECTION MEASURES AMONG
THE CENTRAL PROVISIONS OF THESE
LANDMARK LAWS IS THE RIGHT OF
CONSUMERS TO REQUEST THE
DELETION. OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION OR OPT OUT OF DATA
COLLECTION AND TO REQUIRE
BUSINESSES TO COMPLY WITH SUCH
REQUESTS. AS DIFFERENT PARTIES
HAVE A VALUE WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CONSUMER
PRIVACY LAWS INSTANCES HAVE
EMERGED FOR CLASSIFICATION IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
BUSINESSES CAN MAINTAIN.
CONSUMER DATA TO PROTECT
CONSUMER SAFETY BY RECALLING
AND REPAIRING DEFECTIVE
PRODUCTS ONE OF THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES INVOLVES WARRANTY
AND RECALL REPAIRS WHICH
REQUIRE SHARING OF CONSUMER
DATA BETWEEN THE DEALER. AND
THE MANUFACTURER OF THE PRODUCT.
CURRENTLY BOTH EMERY ENGINE
STEELER OFFENSE BUYER CONTACT
INFORMATION THE PRODUCT
MANUFACTURED. MANUFACTURES USE
THIS INFORMATION TO VERIFY
WARRANTY ELIGIBILITY AND TO
CONDUCT SAFETY RECALLS DEALERS
USE THIS DATA TO VERIFY THE
PRODUCTS OWNERSHIP IN
ELIGIBILITY AT THE POINT OF
REPAIR. AB THREE THREE FIVE
WILL PROVIDE MANUFACTURES THE
LEGAL CERTAINTY THEY NEED TO
COLLECT AND RETAIN THIS
INFORMATION IS TO USE IT TO
PERFORM SAFETY RECALLS. WHILE
BENEFITING CONSUMERS WHO
PURCHASE THEIR PRODUCTS WITH
THIS LIMITED USE OF DATA. BY
ALLOWING THIS LIMITED SHARING
OF INFORMATION CONSUMERS TO BUY
PRODUCTS SUCH AS VESSELS OR
MARINE ENGINES WILL RECEIVE
IMPORTANT AND TIMELY SAFETY
RECALL INFORMATION. AND EASILY
CONFORM WARRANTY VERIFICATION
EIGHTY THREE THREE FIVE WITH
SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT
ALLOW THE USE OF THIS
INFORMATION FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. TODAY WE HAVE WITH
US IN THE REMOTE LOCATION ROOM
MARK SMITH A LOBBYIST FOR THE
NATIONAL MARINE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL. AND ON THE LINE JOEL
MANIC KOLKO MARINE SERVICE
DIVISION. MANAGER YAMAHA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
SOME OF THEM I SEE MRS. IN THE
GALLERY MISTER SMITH- FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU MR CHAIR. MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
MARINE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION ON THE FACE OF IT
THIS BILL IS EXACTLY IDENTICAL
TO ONE APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. WHICH DEALT WITH THIS
ISSUE WITH THE VEHICLE DEALERS
AND VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS. THIS
IS THE SAME CONCEPT BUT FOR
VESSELS. THE CONCERN WE HAVE AS
AND SO MANY FRACTURES IS THAT
WE'RE IN A GRAY AMBIGUOUS AREA
HERE WE HAVE A FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT TO ENACT. RECALL IN
SAFETY WARRANTIES AND WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT WHICH
STATES THAT. BUSINESSES MAY NOT
SHARE THE DATA THAT IS
NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THIS
FEDERAL TRANSACTION. SO ON THE
SURFACE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WILL ALLOW OUR
COMPANIES TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL RECALL AND WARRANTY
MANDATES. THE OPPONENTS OF THE
MEASURE WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRES IT ALL NEW LEGISLATION
IN THIS AREA BE PASSED ONLY IF
IT FURTHERS THE INTERESTS OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION SO TO THAT.
WE SAY THAT THIS BILL DOES THAT
BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME NOW
IT WILL RESTRICT THE USE OF
THIS DATA. FOR THE EXCLUSIVE
PURPOSE OF RECALL MORE T.
MANUFACTURE WILL NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO USE THE DATA TO SAY HEY
YOU BOUGHT MY BOAT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. WOULD YOU LIKE TO BUY
MY TWENTY TWENTY ONE VERSION OR
TO MARKET THAT INFORMATION TO
SOMEBODY ELSE SO THIS BILL DOES
GO A STEP FURTHER IN PROTECTING
CONSUMER DATA. WILL
ADDITIONALLY SAY THAT IF WE
DON'T GET THE DATA FROM A
DEALER WE HAVE A FEDERAL
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE THIS
SERVICE WE WILL BE FORCED TO GO
TO THIRD PARTY DATA VENDORS TO
TRY TO ASSEMBLE. THIS
INFORMATION SO BY ALLOWING THE
SHARING OF INFORMATION ALLOWING
THIS CLARIFICATION WILL BE
CUTTING DOWN ON THE NEED TO GO
TO THIRD PARTY DATA VENDORS.
WHICH IS ALSO A BENEFIT TO
CONSUMERS AND CONSUMER PRIVACY
WE ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
SMITH AND I WAS REMISS IN NOT
ANNOUNCING. THE RULES OF THE
ROAD FOR TODAY'S HEARING
INCLUDING THIS BILL ALL OF THE
LITTLE FALL. DO CAN REGARD
LENGTH OF. TO CAN. INCLUDING I
MISS TIED ON. EACH SUB
PERMITTED AMOUNT OF TIME. WHICH
IS TWO WITNESSES. EACH WITNESS
SHALL HAVE TWO MINUTES FOR A
TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES. TERMS OF
TESTIFYING WITNESSES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
CARE TO JUST VOICE YOUR SUPPORT
YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME. YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION-
MR MANISCALCO MRS MANISCALCO I
BELIEVE IS ON THE PHONE. MR
MANISCALCO ARE YOU AVAILABLE IT.
YES I AM ALL RIGHT FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JOE MENA BUT I'M-
GONNA. L. YOUNG AT THE AIRPORT
FRIENDS IN CYPRUS. YEAH MY THE.
YOU'RE A- AND WHAT KIND OF THAT
ON IT. BETTER OLD BIRD CAP HEY
PERSONAL BATTLE PARK IT. AT
MANAGER OF. HI MONICA TELL YOU.
PARDON ME SIR YOU DON'T YOU
NEED TO BE GIVE YOU. SO I DO
THAT RIGHT NOW. MISTER MAN IS
IT OKAY IF I CONTINUE YES GO
AHEAD. AT THREE SERVICE. I
UNEQUIVOCALLY TELL YOU THAT.
YOU INFORM US OF. SO THAT WE
CAN MAINTAIN RECORDS. FEDERAL
CALL IT A DETECTOR AT AND THEIR
IMPACT IN ANY. AND I'M SURE YOU
CAN IMAGINE. FAILURE OF A KEY
MOMENT. AND WHETHER IN THE LAKE
BURT TWENTY MONTHS OR- EVERYONE.
IT HOWEVER ORDER TO AT. THE
MANAGER ALL BOTH. UNITS A
TECHNICAL. CALIFORNIA LAW AT.
WE HAVE TO REACH OUT AND THEN
AND- OUR DATA BUT TEN NODE BUT
LIKE THINK. THAT DATA FOR THE.
THERE WILL BE I NEVER. THE
CONSUMER THREE. OR IT IS THAT.
YOU ARE AS WRITTEN IN BIG PART.
DATA ARE. SO DO THE IS TO
INFORM THE OTHER ALL RIGHT. ON
BEHALF IN BUT- WE WISH TO PRESS
THEIR FOR YOUR IT AT ASK YOUR
I'VE- THANKS THANK YOU MR
MANISCALCO- IT IS FOR AGAIN TO
EVERY BILL THAT- THOSE OF YOU
ARE WATCHING OR LISTENING IF
YOU CARE TO SUBMIT COMMENTS-
YOU CAN DO SO BY ACCESSING THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND YOU MAY
SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS AS
WELL. ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN
THE OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I
SEE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATE LET'S TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES. FOR WAKING UP
THE CHAIR IS THAT. BUT IT IS A
GENTLEMAN IF YOU SHOULD FOR OF
AB. THREE THIRTY. LONDON ZERO.
IF YOU CAN MAKE A MOMENT TO
CHAIR THERE'S AN ECHO. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE
THREE FIVE RESPECT ONE ZERO.
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR INE NUMBER IN PLACE YOU
BACK AND YOU. GET THAT ONE ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF. EIGHTY THREE THIRTY FIVE.
THE MESSAGE HERE WE HAVE TWO
PEOPLE WE HAVE THREE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP THERE. THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD MY NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE REMEMBERS YOUR
RETIREMENT ALL THE HELP OF
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA. HOLD OUT BECAUSE HE-
IN SUPPORT OF VOTER INTEREST IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BOW BILLER ON BEHALF OF
THE GREEN RECREATION
ASSOCIATION ON THE CALIFORNIA
HARBOR. MASTERS REPORT CAPTAINS.
YOUR THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A-
NO SHOW YOU'VE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- I'M A WITNESS NOT
TO MENTION. RIGHT TIME ALL
RIGHT LOCAL OPPOSITION JUST A
MOMENT OF ANYONE ELSE MODERATOR
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MESSAGE
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE OF
THE SUPPORT OF A B. THREE
THIRTY FIVE. ALL RIGHT- LET'S
NOW TURN TO THE OPPOSITION-
OPPOSITION WILL HAVE EQUAL TIME
WITH THEIR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. WILL PROVIDE THEM-
TWO MINUTES. EACH FOR THE FIRST
TWO WITNESSES- I SEE NO ONE
LISTED AS MAIN OPPOSITION.
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION NO ANYONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S TOWN TURNED
TO THE PHONE LINES. ON THE
PHONE LINES ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH SPEAK IN OPPOSITION HI
BABY THREE THIRTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. A
BABY THREE FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THERE- NOW. THANK YOU
MESSAGE HERE WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE
IN Q. LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
MR CHAIR INTO THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS JACOB NOW
I'M A TECHNOLOGY AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES ATTORNEY AT THE ACLU
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE TODAY BECAUSE
EIGHTY THREE THIRTY FIVE
REPRESENTS A STEP BACKWARD FOR
CONSUMER PRIVACY AND IT
CONSTITUTES AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
RIGHT BACK TO TWENTY TWENTY THE
INITIATIVE KNOWN AS PROPOSITION
TWENTY FOUR ON THE BALLOT LAST
NOVEMBER. LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
THE BALLOT INITIATIVES CAN BE
AMENDED BY THE LEGISLATURE ONLY
WHEN THEIR TERMS PERMIT THOSE
AMENDMENTS. AND PROPERTY FOR
PUT IN PLACE A SIMPLE
RESTRICTION ON AMENDING
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY LAW YOU CAN
ONLY AMEND IT TO ENHANCE
CONSUMER PRIVACY. IT'S A ONE
WAY RATCHET WHERE PRIVACY ONE
CALIFORNIA. ONLY GOT STRONGER
OVER TIME. THE MORE COMPUTERS
IN THE TEXT OF THE INITIATIVE.
IN THE VOTER GUIDE. MUNITIONS
THAT WAS FOR TO THE- I WAS
REPEATING UPSIDE. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PUB DISCUSS. I
PROP. TWENTY ON THE MENTAL
PURPOSE OF THE INITIATIVE WITH
THIS. CONSUMER MAKE AMENDMENTS
YOU CAN OCCUR. AND POSSIBLE BUT
WITHOUT ANOTHER IMAGE. THIRTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE AND FORTY IS
NOT IT'S A WITH RESTRICTION
ELIMINATE THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
SPECIFICALLY THE RYE. FOR
PEOPLE TO OPT OUT OF THE
INFORMATION BEING SOLD OUT FOR
SOMEONE FROM- SO IT'S- WITH
METALS BUSTLING. DOESN'T THE
DIPLOMAT PURPOSE ENHANCING
PRIVACY AND THEREFORE IT'S NOT
A PERMISSIBLE THAT BUT
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY LAW. AS FOR
THE NEW THAT FEDERAL LAW. THAT
IS ACTUALLY A- AND TWO FOUR
DRESSING PREEMPTION BY FEDERAL
LAW NUCOR ORDER THAT- THE STAY
LAWS PRINTED AND HERE THERE'S
NO ORDER TO AMENDMENT. BILL
CORRECTION. IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE. THIS BILL IS ALSO
NOT MESSAGE. BUT NOTHING
STOPPED THE BOAT DEALER FROM.
WITH ABOUT A ABOUT WARRANTY OR
FROM. AND WOMEN THIS IS ABOUT
HONORING POPPED. FOR PERSON
EXPLICITLY SAYS THEY DON'T WANT
THEIR INFORMATION TO BE SOLD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU SIR OTHERS MY NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
FOR OVER SIXTY YEARS I'M NOT
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED AB THREE
THREE FIVE. GENERALLY THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION SUPPORTS
PROVIDING CONSUMERS WITH
GREATER INFORMATION AND
DISCLOSURE WHEN IT COMES TO
RECALLS AND WARRANTY ISSUES
HOWEVER EIGHTY THREE THREE
FIVE. SO IN A WAY THAT IS
INCONSISTENT WITH PROPERTY FOR.
WHICH VOTERS PASSED LAST YEAR
AND ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THE
HYPOTHETICAL PREEMPTION ISSUE
WHICH DOES NOT EXIST YET AND
LIKELY NEVER WILL. TWENTY FOUR
CLEARLY STATES THAT CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY LAW CAN ONLY BE AMENDED
TO QUOTE ENHANCED PRIVACY. THE
PROPONENTS OF PROPOSITION
REPEATEDLY ARGUED THAT THE
INITIATIVE WILL PREVENT THE
TAKING OF AMENDMENTS WE CAN
PRINT THE PROTECTION LOOKING
FOR A- SPECIAL EXEMPTION SOUGHT
BY THE BOOK INDUSTRY IN EIGHTY
THREE THREE FIVE WOULD NOT
ENHANCE PRIVACY BUT INSTEAD OF
ELIMINATING PRIVACY RIGHTS THAT
ALLOW CONSUMERS. OFTEN FAIL
OTHER PRIVATE INFORMATION.
LIMITED BILLBOARD IN THIS WAY
COULD SEND A SIGNAL FOR FUTURE
CHANGES TO THE LAW BY USING UP
ALL POLITICAL THE THIRD COMBA
A LOT. UP TWENTY FOUR IS ALSO
CLEAR THAT IT CAN CAN BE
AMENDED TO ADDRESS A
CALIFORNIA- FEDERAL COURT
RULING. AND THE MERE
POSSIBILITY OF FEDERAL
PREEMPTION IN THE FUTURE. DOES
NOT PROVIDE. THE OPPOSITION
COLD HOW PROVIDED ME ALL CAN
AND- WITH CLEAR LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD HAVE. ALL OF THESE.
LEAVING CROP FOR FOUR ON.
POSSIBLE TELLING BILL. I'M
FORTY THAT PROPOSAL NOT ACCEPT.
AND WE'RE LEFT WITH A BILL THAT
BELIEVE CONFLICT WITH THE
TELLER OF THE PROPERTY. FIFTY
PER ACTIVITY. THANK COMPLICATE
FUTURE EFFORTS THE BAND. AGAIN
WE CAN THE LAW FOR THESE
REASONS ARE CREDIT. OF THE NEED
FOR THREE FIVE AND A CURRENT
FORM AND ASK FOR NO. FOR THE
BILL BE AMENDED ALL THE- THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MODEL ANYONE
ELSE IN OPL ON THE PHONE LINE.
EVERY TIME OF DAY CARE WE HAVE
NO ELSE E. G. ARE LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE CHAIN- DISCUSS
COM YOU SIR WHAT KOWSKI. THANK
YOU MR- I DON'T WANNA ROCK BOAT
HERE BECAUSE IT'S THIS BILL IS.
THIS BILL IS WELL WHAT BUT DONE
SOONER BECAUSE HE- BUT- THE-
CAN. DATA ALL OR PROPONENTS-
THE AUTHOR SAID INDICATED THAT
THEY'VE NEVER. WHAT THE CONCERN
DATA CAN BE USED FOR IS. IT BE
USED TO SELL. TRANS SINCE SORT
OF THE FOLLOW UP WITH LET ME
FIX YOUR BOAT OR LET ME DO
THIS- JUST GIVING THEM THE
WARNING. I A CLEAR FOR FROM
THE- FROM THE AUTHOR IF THAT
ISN'T IN FACT THIS NARROW
NARROWING. OF WHAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY RECEIVE IT SHE SAID
THAT. BOAT IS BROKEN. YES SEVEN
MEMBER BANNER OR WEST BERMUDA
WE'RE NOT BANNER BURNER BURNER
YEAH YES THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
SO CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
INFORMING THE CONSUMER OF
RECALL AND WARRANTY ISSUES WE
DON'T WANT EXPLORING BOTH ON
OUR WATERWAYS AND I THINK THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION ACT AND I HEARD THE
OPPOSITION SPEAK ALSO OF SALE
OF DATA THIS DOES NOT PROVIDE
FOR THE SALE OF DATA THIS
PROVIDES ONLY FOR
MANUFACTURERS. WILL CONTACT
CONSUMERS IN THE CASES OF
WARRANTY AND RECALL. SIX I MEAN
I MISS I WORK OUT THIS I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE BALLOT THE STERN
IS SO I'M NOT I'M NOT SINCE I'M
NOT PROFESSING I UNDERSTAND
HE'S NOT A FULL. TERMS BUT THE
OTHER. CAN THAT I HAD IS ON FED
PREEMPTION. BECAUSE BECAUSE AS
I READ. THE PROPOSITION NO IT'S
I'M LOOKING AT THE TOP OF PAGE
EIGHT WE HAVE IS TO FURTHER
CONSUMER RIGHTS WHICH INCLUDE
THE PRIVACY RIGHTS AND IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THIS NOTICE. TO GIVE
VESSEL OWNERS INFORMATION THAT
YOUR- ENGINE MAY BREAK DOWN IS.
FOUNDATIONAL FOR- THE CONSUMER
RIGHTS ACT I'M- I'D LIKE THE
CLARIFICATION OF THE OPPOSITION
IS SAID THAT YOU NEED A COURT
ORDER FIRST IN ORDER TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF GETTING
COMPLYING WITH FEDERAL LAW. AND
MY READING OF THE CONSTITUTION
IS THE SUPREME X. THE CLAUSE
WOULD SAY THAT THAT WOULD BE
NON BINDING. AND WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS IT TRUE THAT WE NEED
A COURT ORDER IN ORDER TO HAVE-
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
NOTIFICATION THAT- I GUESS AB
THREE THREE FIVE IS TRYING TO
DO THIS SHE GREW WITH THAT.
ANALYSIS OF THE OPPOSITION. SAN
JUAN CASKEY IT IS THAT A
QUESTION TO THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES OR TO THE AUTHORS NO
TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
OPPOSITION ASSERTS THAT THAT
ARTIST YOU CAN'T. YOU CAN'T
NOTIFY CONSUMERS UNLESS YOU GET
A COURT ORDER EXEMPTING EVEN
THEN THAT WOULD TRIGGER THE-
CPR EIGHT. SEVEN NUMBER.
BOEHNER HOWEVER THANK YOU- I DO
NOT AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION
ON THAT POINT SENATOR MCCASKEY.
ALL RIGHT. OTHER QUESTIONS
THERE WERE CASKEY NO MY I'M I
DO NOT WANNA LEAVE ANYBODY IN
MY WEIGHT ON THIS MATTER AND I
THINK I'VE ASKED ALL THE
QUESTIONS I NEED ALL RIGHT HERE
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOU NOT
CONTINUE TO ROCK THE BOAT.
SERVICE WORK. THANK YOU SOMEONE
WHO SPENT OVER THREE HUNDRED
HOURS IN THE NEGOTIATION AND
DRAFTING OF TUG OF PROPOSITION
TWENTY FOUR. BUT THIS IS
PRECISELY WHAT WE WERE
CONSIDERING I'M TRYING TO FIND
SECTION THREE HERE. IF I COULD
JUST TALKS ABOUT AMENDMENTS TO
THE SECTION TWENTY FIVE THE
TALKS ABOUT AMENDMENTS
CONCERNING CONSUMER RIGHTS. BUT
THE ACTUAL SECTION THREE WHICH
TALKS ABOUT WHAT CONSUMER
RIGHTS AREN'T RESPONSIBLE
BUSINESSES IT'S BEACH PROBABLY
OF ALL THE THINGS THAT WE HAD
WITH SOME OF THE OPPONENTS HERE
WHO ALSO OPPONENTS TO PROBE TO
PROP TWENTY FOUR. THAT THEY
ARGUED ABOUT SAYING THAT THE
LANGUAGE OF SECTION. THREE
WHICH DEFINES- THE DEFINITION
OF CONSUMER RIGHTS WAS TOO
BROAD. BECAUSE AS I SUGGESTED
OF ALL THE DISCUSSION WE HAD IN
DRAFTING. A PROPOSITION TWENTY
FOUR THAT THIS WAS ONE OF THE
SECTIONS THAT WAS THE MOST
DIFFICULT AND I'M TRYNG TO
FIND IT. BUT I DON'T THINK I
CAN. AT THIS TIME BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT IN MY VIEW
I STRONGLY STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE THAT IS COMPLETELY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. THIS IS NOT
ANYTHING ABOUT. DOING OTHER
THAN PROTECTING CONSUMERS
THAT'S THE IDEA HERE IT'S
PRIVACY AND CONSUMERS AND
HERE'S A CONSUMER THAT COULD BE
SUBJECT TO SOME TYPE OF RECALL
AND THAT HAS TO BE SOME DOLLARS
PROVISION. MY RECOLLECTION
ALTHOUGH I HAVEN'T REREAD THIS
IN SOME PRETTY TIME IS THAT WE
HAD A VERY SIMILAR PROVISION
HERE WITH RESPECT TO
AUTOMOBILES. AND THE OPPONENTS
THIS DIDN'T OBJECT TO THAT THIS
JUST EXTENDS THE SAME
PROVISIONS TO. THE BOAT SO I
THINK IT'S COMPLETELY
CONSISTENT TITLE TWENTY FOUR
IT'S COMPLETELY CONSISTENT WITH
THE MEASURE WE PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND I
STRENGTH FROM HIS BOOK. THE
USERS WORK SAYING NO OTHER
MICHAEL RAISED- SALUTE THEM
BORDER HER YOU CAN CLOSE I
RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR I. R. IS
MOTIONS. SO KIRBY SAID A COUPLE
MOCAMBO. MEANT SHE KILLED THE
CALL ROLL. YES THIS IS A B. TWO
THREE FIVE WITH THE MOST BY
COPY AT ALL THE IS TO PASS BUT-
TO BE RE. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. AMBERG
HI PORGES. GORGEOUS I CARRY IT
OFF. I DID I SO. DID I SO I
GONZALEZ WHEN SELES I HURTS
BERG HERZBERG FIGHT JONES.
LAYERED STERN STERN I WAKE
HOUSEKI Y. CASKEY I WINNER. YOU
HAVE EIGHT ZERO SO FAR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT MEASURE ON
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU SEVEN
MEMBERS SHALL I SEE YOUR
PRESENCE- NEXT WE HAVE A B.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE FILE NUMBER
THREE AB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS AT THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE SERVES AS AN
EFFECTIVE FIRST STEP. IN
ADDRESSING THE GROWTH OF THE
HACKED DATA MARKETPLACE. BY
MAKING CLEAR THAT NO ONE CAN
KNOWINGLY SELL PURCHASE OR
UTILIZE HACKED DATA. TODAY WE
LIVE IN DIGITALLY CONNECTED
WORLD WHERE MORE PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. THAN
EVER BEFORE. FURTHER ADMITTED
TO PANDEMICS INTERNET ACCESS
HAS QUICKLY BECOME A BASIC
NECESSITY FOR ALL ASPECTS OF
LIFE. HOWEVER AS MANY MORE
PEOPLE USE COMPUTERS AND THE
INTERNET TO CRIMINALS HAVE ALSO
HAVE MORE. OPPORTUNITIES TO
HACK INFORMATION IN THE FIRST
HALF OF TWENTY NINETEEN IN
FACT. DATA BREACHES EXPOSED
FOUR POINT ONE BILLION RECORDS.
YEAH IN THE FIRST HALF OF
TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY SIX
BILLION RECORDS WERE EXPOSED.
THESE TYPES OF CYBERCRIMES
RANGE FROM BREAKING INTO ONE'S
COMPUTER NETWORK TO STEALING
FINANCIAL INFORMATION TO OTHER
CRIMES SUCH AS A CORPORATE
ESPIONAGE. FRAUD AND EXTORTION.
CURRENT LOCAL. COMPUTER HACKING
AND STEALING INFORMATION IN ALL
FORMS NEVERTHELESS SOME
COMPANIES HAVE SEIZED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TURN A PROFIT BY
SELLING DATA ORIGINALLY
OBTAINED BY HACKERS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIRD PARTIES.
FOR EXAMPLE THE NEWS RECENTLY
REPORTED ON A COMPANY THAT
SELLS ACCESS TO BREACHED
PERSONAL DATA INCLUDING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AS A STATE THAT IS
HOME TO SOME OF THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE LAWS PROTECTING
YOUR TRONIC COMMUNICATIONS WHEN
AND WHERE THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY
IS ENSHRINED IN OUR
CONSTITUTION. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
LEAD THE WAY IN STOPPING THE
RISE OF HACKED DATA
MARKETPLACE. AB THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE WILL MAKE IT UNLAWFUL FOR A
PERSON TO SELL PURCHASE OR
UTILIZE DATA AS DEFINED THAT
THE PERSON KNOWS OR REASONABLY
SHOULD KNOW IS COMPROMISED
DATA. SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. ALL RIGHT-
SIMILAR CHANNEL ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT I DON'T BELIEVE SO
NO ALL RIGHT ALL I SEE THE LOOK
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT- TOURNEY ROOM ONE
TWELVE I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. IN SUPPORT.
NOW LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
QUEUE THEM UP. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER IN PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THIRTEEN NINETY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW. AND
AT THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION- I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY. WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WHICH INTENSIFIED
OPPOSITION. LET'S TURN THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR. ARE
THERE. ANY PERSONS ON THE PHONE
WHICH IS TESTIFIED. IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB ONE THREE
NINE ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
A. B. ONE THREE NINE ONE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE-
NOW. AND AT THIS TIME IF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR. I
SEE NO MICROPHONES RAISED.
EXCEPT FOR CENTER WHITE HOUSE
USE. A SURVEY CASKEY. I WAS
WONDERING IF THE AUTHOR COULD
GIVE US SOME CLARIFICATION ON
HOW HE'S HARMONIZE THIS BILL
WITH THE BAR NIKKI. DECISION
BECAUSE IT APPEARS THAT HE'S-
IF YOU USE IF YOU TO OBTAIN THE
DATA AND YOU SELL IT WHICH WE
NORMALLY THINK OF COMMERCIAL
SPEECH THEN THAT'S THAT'S WHO
HE'S GOING AFTER BUT IF PEOPLE.
ARE WHISTLE BLOWERS ORDERED THE
PRESS AND THEY EXPOSE THIS DATA
THAN THEY WOULD BE THEY WOULD
HAVE A CARVE OUT I GUESS MY
QUESTION WAS IF SOMEBODY. PUTS
ALL THIS DATA ON THE INTERNET
THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO MAKE ANY
MONEY OFF OF IT IS THAT GOING
TO BE PROTECTED UNDER. PAR
NIKKI IN THE SOLOMON R. CASES.
SO NUMBER CHILD GET A RESPONSE
SURE THANKS FOR THE QUESTION
THE POOR NEED T. CASE
ESSENTIALLY IS A TWO THOUSAND
ONES R. U. S. SUPREME COURT'S
CASE WHICH I HELD THAT. FIRST
AMENDMENT PROVIDES PROTECTION
TO SPEECH THAT THIS CLOSES THE
CONTENT OF ILLEGALLY
INTERCEPTED COMMUNICATIONS. AND
IN THIS CASE COMMUNICATION ARE
RELATED TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IF I UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY AND IN ALL CASES- WE
HAVE ACTUALLY CARVED OUT ANY-
PIECES RELATED UNDER BY NIKKI
SAID THAT- WE ARE PROTECTING.
FIRST AMENDMENT- RIGHT SPEECHES
AS WELL AS LET'S SAY A WHISTLE
BLOWERS AND- YOU KNOW THE PRESS
SO AS FAR AS YOUR EXAMPLE I
THINK IT WILL. COME UNDER THEY
WILL COME UNDER- AT THIS POINT
EIGHTY CASE AS WELL- BUT- HE-
YOU KNOW SO. BUT ALSO AT THE
SAME TIME WE'RE TARGETING THIRD
PARTY SELLERS OF INFORMATION
RIGHT SO IF THE INFORMATION IS
OUT THERE. ON THE INTERNET- DAN
YOU KNOW PERHAPS- YOU KNOW THEY
THEY WOULD NOT BE SO. THEY WILL
NOT BE UNDER THE SALE CATEGORY
SO TO SPEAK. SO THAT THAT WOULD
BE MY EXPLANATION. THANK YOU.
OTHERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS I SEE
NO OTHER MICROPHONES RAISED
MOVED THE BILL- CINEMA KELSEY
MOVES THE BILL. SO REMEMBER
CHARITY CARE CLOSE HI I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT
THANK YOU SENATOR YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF
YOU CALL THE ROLL. IS THE A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
GIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
AMBERG HI. I'M BURGER I BURGESS.
GUERRERO GUERRERO I DID ALSO.
YEAH SO I CONSOLIDATES.
CONSULATES I HURTS BERG.
HERZBERG I'D JONES. LAYERED
STERN STERN I WAKE OWSKI WHY
CASKEY I WINNER. YES SEVEN TWO
ZERO RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PUT THAT ON HOLD- I SEE SELENA
REMAND SHINE HERE A. B. FIVE
FIVE SIX PHYLUM NUMBER ELEVEN
JUST TO ALERT THE MEMBERS THIS
IS THE NEXT TO LAST BILL THAT
WILL BE HEARING IT. TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN- HERE AS
WELL- FERTILITY PRODUCT HERS
WHEN A DOCTOR THAT SPECIALIZES
IN ASSISTED REPRODUCTIVE
MEDICINE KNOWINGLY IMPLANTS ARE
PATIENT WITH THE SPERM SAMPLE.
THAT IS NOT THE ONE SELECTED
FROM THE DONOR BANK BUT INSTEAD
IS FROM THE DOCTOR HIMSELF.
THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA HAS
ENACTED STRICT LAWS AGAINST
THESE PRACTICES LAST YEAR AFTER
THE B. TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH
CHANGE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ON THESE CRIMES.
NOW TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB
FIVE FIVE SIX WHICH FOCUSES ON
ANOTHER ASPECT OF FERTILITY
FRAUD. CHOOSING TO UTILIZE AND
UNDERGO ASSISTED REPRODUCTIVE
MEDICINE CAN BE COSTLY. VICTIMS
OF FERTILITY FRAUD CAN BE HURT
FINANCIALLY AS SOME PARENTS USE
THEIR ENTIRE. SAVINGS TO
CONCEIVE A FAMILY THROUGH
ASSISTED REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE.
AB FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD PROVIDE
VICTIMS WITH THE ABILITY TO
SEEK DAMAGES IN CALIFORNIA
COURTS. THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
ANOTHER AVENUE FOR JUSTICE FOR
THESE VICTIMS. HAVE WITH ME
TODAY- TELEPHONICALLY I HAVE
JACKIE SANA. WITH THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED- A
CERTAIN ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YEAH
ALL RIGHT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
FOR THE AFTERNOON FAIR NUMBERS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS YES WE CAN HERE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JACKIE
FERNANDEZ DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CONSUMER TRADE BUT
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE SIX. THE BILL WILL ENABLE
THE PHYSICAL CONTRADICTION FOR
PARTICULARLY EGREGIOUS ACT OF
FERTILITY FRAUD. WHEN A PERSON
MISUSES FIRM OVER OUR EMBRYOS.
AND VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
OUR MEMBERS ARE CONSUMERS BUT
NOT FOR THE DATA LOSSES OF
GENETIC MATERIAL INFERTILITY
INDUSTRY FAILURES. AND IT IS
HARD TO DESCRIBE THE SHOCK AND
GRIEF AMONG THEM COULD SUFFER
SUCH A LOSS. THE FERTILITY
PROBLEMS OF THE GRUELING
PHYSICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY.
WOMEN TAKE A COCKTAIL OF
MEDICATIONS UNDERGO NUMEROUS
FLIGHT PATH PUBLIC ADVANTAGE I
CAN SELL OR MOVE BACK BECAUSE-
I'M FOR AND CAN LEAD TO SEVERE
COMPLICATIONS- FAMILIES BOTH.
MORE THAN ONE CYCLE OFTEN. AND
IT COMES AT A HEFTY PRICE TAG
OF ANYWHERE BETWEEN FIFTEEN TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
CYCLE. UNFORTUNATELY THE WOMEN
AND FAMILY COULD FACE THEIR
TRUST IN THE INDUSTRY THAT THEY
FIND THEIR PRECIOUS GENETIC
MATERIAL ARE SOMETIMES. THEY
FOUND A FERTILITY FRAUD AND
ABUSE. ONE AND BEAT THE
INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT A
PATCHWORK OF REGULATIONS AND
SELF OVERSIGHT. HAS RESULTED IN
A CLEAR AND A LACK OF.
CONSISTENT STANDARDS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE SECURITY
INDUSTRY. ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS
HIGHLIGHT HOW THE INDUSTRY IS
RIPE FOR FRAUD AND ABUSE AND
MEASURES LIKE EIGHTY FIVE RIGHT
THEY'RE CRITICAL TO JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR
VICTIMS WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
IT IS CRITICAL STEPS TOWARD
IMPROVING THE INDUSTRY. WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE FAMILY MEMBER
FOR HIS IMPORTANT WORK AND HOPE
THE LEGISLATURE BUT THAT IS
NOTHING MORE COMPREHENSIVE.
SOLUTIONS GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I SEE NONE OF THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- TURNING TO THE PHONES.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE THEM UP. THANKYOU
MEDICARE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. FIVE FIVE SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER ND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB. FIVE
FIVE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
THEIR OWN NOW. AT THE TIME OF
THIS YEAR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. I
HAVE NO- IDENTIFIED MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BUT LET'S
LOOK TO THE GALLERY AND SEEING
NINE ORDER ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
AS WELL- MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO.
AB FIVE FIVE SIX. THANK YOU AT
THE CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE FIVE SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE FIVE SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE BEEN THERE- NOW. AND AT
THIS TIME A TEACHER WE HAVE NO
ONE TO YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DURING THE CHAMBER ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS IN THE
CHAMBER I SEE NO MICROPHONES
RAISED. SO IS THERE A MOTION
YES- ACCOUNTS CAN MOVE THE BILL.
THE WINNER MENTIONED YOU COULD
CLOSE I THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I'VE
GOT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AHMED CHIEF COUNSEL IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
EIGHTY FIVE FIVE SIX ARE WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE GIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG BY AMBER
I BOARD YES. ABIERTO CARRY IT
OFF I DID I SO. DID I SO I AM
GOING SELES. WHEN SELES I HURTS
BERG. HERTZBERG HI JONES
LAYERED STERN STERN I AM WHITE
HOUSE KEY HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER. YOU HAVE SEVENTY ZERO
SO FAR. THEY WERE MUCH WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL THE NEXT WE HAVE A
SIMILAR NUMBER OR ALMOST WHO
HAS BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY HERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO REMEMBER
ALMOST- SOON AS THE MICROPHONE
AND THE- PHOTO MARK. CLEANED
AND WHICH THEY'RE NOW CLEAN
SEVEN ARRIVALS. EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE FIVE FILE NUMBER TWELVE
THIS IS THE LAST BILL WILL BE
HEARING. TODAY INDISCRIMINATE
ESSENTIAL HERTZBERG TO NOTE THE
ALACRITY WITH WHICH WE
PROCEEDED TODAY. ALL RIGHTS-
MEMORABLES. THANK YOU- THANK
MISTER CHAIR AND THEN SENATORS
I INTRODUCED AB EIGHT FIVE FIVE
AT THE REQUEST OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. IT WOULD ESTABLISH FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY. A
BRANCH OF CALIFORNIA TO HONOR
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
AS A PAID HOLIDAY. WITHOUT
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF PAID
COURT HOLIDAYS. THE STATE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PERSONNEL ARE
COVERED UNDER A SEPARATE CODE
SECTION FROM OTHER STATE
WORKERS SECTION. ONE THREE FIVE
OF THE CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE.
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
IS ALREADY A STATE HOLIDAY IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT I LOBBIED
THEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER JO BACHA TO
INTRODUCE A B. NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE. THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
BY GOVERNOR PETE WILSON. THAT
DESIGNATION THE FOURTH FRIDAY
OF SEPTEMBER AS NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY WAS PUT FORWARD BUT ALSO
WAS UNPAID HOLIDAY. FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS I HAVE WORKED
TOWARD CREATING A PAID STATE
HOLIDAY TO RECOGNIZE AND LEARN
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE.
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LIKE THE MANY ROWS
THAT WE TRAVEL WHERE ONCE
INDIAN TRAILS. IN REDLANDS MY
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
REDLANDS BROUGHT WATER TO THAT
COMMUNITY SO IT COULD FLOURISH
THIS BILL STARTS TO SHOW
APPRECIATION OF THESE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND MANY MORE. I
WANT TO THANK THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FOR BRINGING THIS
PROPOSAL FORWARD. YOU
CALIFORNIANS KNOWS MUCH ABOUT
THE STATE'S NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY AND CULTURE DESPITE THE
FACT THAT OUR STATE HAS MORE
NATIVE AMERICANS LIVING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAN ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE NATION. THIS
BILL WOULD BE THE FIRST STEP
TOWARD CORRECTING THAT A
MISSION OF CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE. I ASK THIS
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE AB EIGHT
FIVE FIVE AND ALLOW THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO MAKE THIS
CHANGE. THIS WOULD CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE HITORY
OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE.
JOINING ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
MONTEREY CITY COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE AND CHAIR OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL LEGISLATION
COMMITTEE THE HONORABLE JUDGE
MARLOWE ANDERSON. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROMMEL'S- JUDGE
ANDERSON WELCOME IF YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE ON
BURKE AS WELL AS THE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE A FEW BRIEF COMMENTS
REGARDING EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE- THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE WOULD YOU DESIGNATE
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY AT THE
JUDICIAL HOLIDAY. IN LIEU OF
COLUMBUS DAY BY RECOGNIZING
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY AS A
JUDICIAL HOLIDAY EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE FURTHERS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PERMISSION TO
REMOVE BARRIERS TO ACCESS AND
FAIRNESS. BY BEING RESPONSIVE
TO THE STATE'S CULTURAL AND
ETHNIC DIVERSITY. EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE ALIGNS THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH WITH. OTHER BRANCHES OF
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT. IT IS
A BRANCH. ARE SET IN. THE
COURTS ARE THE ONLY PART OF
STATE GOVERNMENT BUT STILL
CLOSES ITS DOORS IN OBSERVANCE
OF COLUMBUS DAY. COLUMBUS DAY
WILL CONTINUE TO BE A STATE
HOLIDAY BUT- LIKE OTHER STATE
OFFICES WILL BE OPEN FOR
BUSINESS. ON THE SECOND MONDAY
IN OCTOBER. BY EXCHANGING
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY FOR
COLUMBUS DAY THE COURTS WILL
MAINTAIN THE SAME NUMBER OF
JUDICIAL HOLIDAYS. THIS ENSURES
THAT SAME LEVEL OF ACCESS TO
THE COURTS ALL WHILE ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF NATIVE
AMERICANS THE CALIFORNIA AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO EXPRESS OUR
SPONSORSHIP OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU JUDGE
ANDERSON ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
I SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
MODERATOR IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU
WOULD. GIVE THEM UP. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. IN
LINE A THIRTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND-
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF MORONGO BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE. GIVE. AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GIVE
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER. END OF
LIFE THIRTY FOUR YEAR MY COULD
OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
AFRIKA VARGAS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE DRY CREEK RANCHERIA BAND OF
POMO INDIANS WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORT OF A. B. EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
ALMOST FOR. WATERING THE SPILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE MAN MENTORED AND MR SURE
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW
TURN THE OPPOSITION- I SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE- MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE LINE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO ROUTE
TWO EIGHTY. EIGHT FIVE FIVE.
SORT COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
A. B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE THREE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THE
TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE TO
THE CHAMBER I SEE MR CENTER
BOARD IS MIKE. IS UP. SIR
BURGESS YES I'D LIKE TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
ITEM FORD AND OF COURSE THE
SIGNIFICANCE- THAT IT HAS NOT
ONLY IN OUR NATIVE AMERICAN.
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO I THINK IN
MAKING CERTAIN THAT WE HATE
PROPER SPECS ARE ON FOR THE
HERITAGE AND CULTURE THAT HAVE
COME ALONG WITH THEIR NATIVE.
PEOPLES JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IF I MAY BE THROUGH
THE CHAIR POSE TO THE AUTHOR IF
YOU'LL ACCEPT- THIS WOULD BE
TAKING THE PAID PORTION OF
ANOTHER HOLIDAY. TO ATTACH IT
TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN- HOLIDAY.
I WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THERE IS A HIGH HEALTHY AMOUNT
OF RESPECT FOR THOSE THAT DO-
HONOR AND RECOGNIZE OUR
COLUMBUS DAY THAT THIS IS NO
FAT IN NO WAY OR FASHION. WILL
LIMIT COLUMBUSDAY FROM THE
LIST OF HOLIDAYS IT'S JUST THE
PAID COMPONENT THAT WILL BE
GOING TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY IS THAT CORRECT. YES THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION CENTER AND
THAT IS CORRECT THIS IN THIS
BILL IN NO WAY. WILL TAKE AWAY-
COLUMBUS DAY AS A HOLIDAY. BUT
WILL- EXCHANGE COLUMBUS DAY AS
A PAID HOLIDAY IN EXCHANGE FOR
A CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY- THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL-
DOES A. B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE SO I
THINK IT BALANCES THAT
APPROACH. CAN LAST QUESTION-
WOULD BE THAT- THERE ARE ARE
YOU AWARE OF- OF ANY DESIGNS
TO. ELIMINATE COLUMBUS DAY. AS
A RECOGNIZED HOLIDAY. EITHER
NOW OR IN THE COMING-
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE OR
THEREAFTER. THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION AGAIN SENATOR AND ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AS A FAMILY
MEMBER THERE IS NO MOVEMENT ON
BEHALF OF- ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
THE FOURTEENTH DISTRICT MOVING
FORWARD IN THAT FASHION R. WITH
THAT BEING SAID- I LIKE IT
MENTIONED. I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT
THIS TODAY I DO BELIEVE THAT.
WE DO NEED TO- PRESERVER
HISTORY. ON THAT INCLUDES NOT
ONLY ELEVATING NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY BUT ALSO MAKING CERTAIN
THAT COLUMBUS DAY. IS A DAY
THAT WE CELEBRATE FOR MANY FOR
MANY REASONS- WITH THAT'LL BE
SUPPORTED THANK YOU. THANK
CENTER BOARD JUST- OTHERS I SEE
SENATOR STERN'S MICROPHONES
RAISED CENTER STERN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER- FOUR
NOTCHES HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
THIS LEGISLATION BUT- FOR
EDUCATING ALL OF US AND NOT
JUST LEAVING IT IN THE
LEGISLATURE HERE BUT- TRYING TO
TAKE IT TO. THE PEOPLE- WE LIVE
ON NATIVE LANDS- MONKS FIRST
PEOPLES AND WE OFTEN DON'T EVEN
KNOW ON THE GROUND ON WHICH WE
STAND- APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATION I WOULD LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A- CO AUTHOR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- SHOULD HAVE
FURTHER AMENDMENTS BE TAKEN.
AND I WOULD SAY- WITH DUE
RESPECT TO MY- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO- MEANWHILE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAY NOT HAVE
THOSE DESIGNS IN MIND I DO
THINK MIGHT MY LEGISLATION
STALLED OUT- LAST SESSION- ON
ENDING COLUMBUS DAY- I DO
THINK- REFERENCE FOR- REDIFF.
OF ENSLAVEMENT AND COLONIALISM
IS FAR OUTLIVED ITS TIME BUT I
HAVE IMMENSE RESPECT FOR- FOR
THE WORK GOING ON HERE IN THIS
SORT OF ORDERLY PACE OF THINGS
SO I'LL- I'LL DEFER- ON THAT
MATTER BUT I WOULD SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW THE ROTUNDA AND OUR
RECTIFICATION IN THIS CAPITAL
IS JUST ONE START- BUT- YOU
KNOW WHEN I GO DOWN THE TEN
FREEWAY EVERY DAY IN LA. I LOOK
AT THAT TUNNEL I THINK TO
MYSELF ONLY WE KNEW WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED WHEN- COLUMBUS SAILED
THE OCEAN BLUE. SO WITH THAT
ARE YOU SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
SEEING NONE. ALL RIGHT I'LL
BRING IT BACK- IS THERE A
MOTION. THE CENTER ALSO MOST OF
BILL. A SALOON OR ALMOST YOU
COULD CLOSE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I THINK-
SENATOR STERN AND A SENATOR
WIENER AND SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR
AGREEING TO COME ON AS CO
AUTHORS- TO BE ADDED TO THIS
BILL. AND I WANT TO THANK HIS
COMMITTEE AND- THE PRESENTATION
THAT'S HERE AND THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTIONS I CLOSE AND ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALMOST A MINUTE YOU
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL- THIS IS THE LAST BILL.
THAT WILL BE HEARING TODAY SO
GO AHEAD. THIS IS A. B. EIGHT
FIVE FIVE- WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR DID US SO- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BEAT RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI AMBER
GUY BURGESS. PORGES I HAVE A
ZERO. VALUE AT ALL I DID US
ALL. THE REST SO I ONCE I LIST
WHEN SELES I HURTS BERG.
HERZBERG I JONES. LAYERED STERN
STERN HIGHWAY CASKEY HI MY
CASKEY I WINNER. ARE YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE EIGHT TO ZERO SO FAR
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL- ALL RIGHT MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL A LET'S LIVE CALLS- FOR
THOSE OF YOU ARE LISTENING- WE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN HERE
FOR A FEW MOMENTS TO ALLOW I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ANOTHER-
EVENT GOING ON IN THE CAPITAL.
THIS IS OCCUPIED AT LEAST
COUPLE MEMBERS SO- WHAT WILL
KEEP THE ROLL UP IN HERE FOR A
LITTLE WHILE ALL RIGHT. SO ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR COVEY
IT'LL- CARRY IT OUT I DID I SO.
DID I SO I HURTS BERG. HURTS
BERG I STERN. STERN II WINNER.
SO YOU HAVE TEN TO ZERO SO FAR
WITH ONE MEMBER MISSING. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WHAT WILL KEEP
IT OPEN NEXT WE HAVE- AB THREE
THREE FIVE BY BOERNER HORVATH
AND- WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI.
HURTS I'M SORRY JONES JONES I
LAYERED WINNER- YOU HAVE NINE
TWO ZERO WITH TWO MEMBERS
MISSING. SORRY BUT NOT OUT OF
CONTROL OKAY. NEXT WE HAVE A B.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHILD- WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I BARGES BARGES I JONES
HI JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED I
WINNER YOU HAVE TEN TO ZERO
WITH ONE MEMBER MISSING ON THAT
ONE. ALL RIGHT BACK ON CALL
OKAY AND THE NEXT ONE IS E. B.
FIVE FIVE SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
MAIN SHINE. WITH THE- THE CHAIR
VOTING HI BORJAS. THIS IS
EIGHTY FIVE FIVE SIX BY MAIN
SHINE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
RIGHT NOW IT'S SEVEN TWO ZERO.
OKAY SO GORGEOUS BY BORDERS HI
JONES HI. I'M TERRY JONES.
JONES HI LAYERED. LAYERED I
WEINER OKAY WE HAVE TEN TO ZERO
WITH ONE MEMBER MISSING ON THAT
ONE ALL RIGHT BACK ON CALL
SECOND CALL- AND THEN WE HAVE
A. B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FROM US. WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING HI JONES.
JONES NOT VOTING LAYERED.
LAYERED I WINNER. SOMEONE THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE NINE ZERO WITH
ONE MEMBER MISSING ALL RIGHT- I
THINK THAT CONCLUDES TODAY'S-BUSINESS I SEE SERRA LAYERED
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED. BILL
ON STILL NOT ON THE FIELD YEAH
ALL RIGHT WE'LL BE BACK. SURE
WHATEVER WHATEVER THAT IS WHAT
THE SENATOR WIENER I THINK IT'S
COMING MOMENTARILY SO- IT WHY
DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
ROLE ON THE BUILDING CENTER
LAYERED WHICH IS TWO FOLD POND
SURE THING- THAT WOULD BE. AB
THREE THREE FIVE BY BOERNER
HORVATH WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
LAYERED. WHERE'D I WINNER CASEY
UP TEN TO ZERO ON THAT ONE SO
FAR I. THANK YOU. YEAH. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WHEN WE GO AHEAD LIVE
CALLS. OKAY THE FIRST ITEM IS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WEINER
WINNER I'D THAT'S ELEVEN TWO
ZERO SHARE THAT IS ALL- THE
NEXT ITEM IS AB THREE THREE
FIVE BYE BURNER FOR VAST. FIVE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I. WINNER
WINNER I THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO
THAT IS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
AB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOW WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I WINNER. WINNER I
THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO. ALL
RIGHT. THE NETTLES OUT THANK
YOU THE NEXT ITEM IS AB FIVE
FIVE SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAN
SHINE AND- THAT YOU'RE VOTING I
AM WIENER. WINNER I THAT'S
ELEVEN TWO ZERO BILLS OUT. AND
THE NEXT ITEM IS AB EIGHT FIVE
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARAMELS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I WINNER.
WINNER I THAT'S. TEN TWO ZERO.
ALL RIGHT BILLS OUT. I THINK
THAT CONCLUDES OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY HEARING FOR TODAY
WE'LL RECONVENE NEXT TUESDAY AT
ONE THIRTY- WE'RE GERMAN.